hello and welcome to the Evan Carmichael
show I believe in entrepreneurs I want
to see you have massive success with
your company and I'm you know I'm tired
of seeing entrepreneurs struggle and I'm
not talking about the guys are just
trying to rip you off and just trying to
you know take all your money if that's
you you know I have no interest in
helping you but if you are trying to do
something important if you're trying to
help people if you're trying to you're
trying to build a better life for
yourself and your family and you're
struggling you feel like you tried
everything and nothing's working and you
need some help this show is for you this
is my last show of the year I'm excited
the lineup that I have today here's what
I'm talking about decide how to pay your
employees how to convince a customer to
buy from you and should i leave my job
to focus on my business you know the
real problem is that you haven't decided
to become an entrepreneur if you are
sitting on the fence and you're not sure
if you're going to do this or not then I
can't help you yet you know I can answer
your question but you're not going to
take any action all the advice in the
world is not going to help you until you
decide that this is for you when you
decide something when this is now the
person that you're going to be it made a
big change in your life that small
decision changes who you are because now
the problems that you see in front of
you you're going to actively seek out
solutions you have to because you've
decided this is a party going to take
whatever your goal is in life you have
to go out and decide that that is the
person you're going to be and this isn't
just business is personal to you want to
lose 15 pounds you have to decide that
that's first you're going to be and
until you get there I can't really help
you you think you got problems now wait
to get started this is a hard thing that
you're doing here and the good news is
every problem that you're going to come
up against can be solved if you decide
you want to find a solution it's going
to happen
have to first decide that you want to be
an entrepreneur here's a quick example
that might help bring it home what was
the last time you bought a car they
think about the last time you bought a
car ask you Bob did you start to see it
everywhere on the streets and the
highways and your neighborhood you
suddenly start seeing that same car
everywhere why is that it's not because
everybody went out and bought the same
car that week they were always there you
just didn't see it does your brain
ignores 99% of the stuff that comes in
there's too much information to handle
once you decided to buy that car you
started to see it in your environment
you started to pay attention to it and
notice that the same thing happens with
your business once you decide to be an
entrepreneur you're going to see things
in your environment your current
environment that will help you solve the
problems that are ahead but you have to
decide this is one thing that I don't
have a lot of empathy for okay when when
people call into the show and if you're
talking about struggling if you're
talking about having enough money you're
talking about how do I find my first
customer you're talking about how do I
you know make my rent payment on time I
went through all that stuff okay I can
emphasize I was a guy making 300 bucks a
month and eating beans for lunch every
day I celebrated a big win with
McDonald's french fries okay I was there
and I busted through but I don't have
empathy for people who are just dreamers
to be an entrepreneur you can't just be
a dreamer you have to be a doer you've
got to take action I don't have a
20-year visions for myself I don't know
what I'm going to be in twitter i don't
know going to be next year if I want
something I go after it I started
talking it right now and doesn't mean
it's going to happen right now I'm not
expecting your gold the accomplished
next week if it's if it's a goal worth
fighting for you're not going to have it
happen in one week
but the fact is you start making
progress you make a decision that this
is the person you're going to be and you
start attacking it so if you want to be
an entrepreneur have to make that
decision first I am an entrepreneur and
I'm going to solve these problems ahead
of me and I'm going to build this
business than the advice will help they
want to get to the call I have hate on
the line Kate where are you from and how
can I help hey there I'm from Texas and
one say that I love the show and I'm
real excited to be able to talk to you I
am an artist manager for individuals
that want to get want to get noticed by
the media whether they're actors or
whether they're guest experts I help
them you know build their little bridge
to being from a being regular person to
being noticed in the media don't excited
and i've got probably six clients that
are paying me an average of about three
hundred dollars a month so I'm excited
and I'm working hard on that and it's
not work because I love doing it a
question is they all signed up at
different times during the month and so
I don't know since it's not a lot of
money yet and I'm and we'll have to call
back with my budget question but I don't
know if I should wind them all up to
come in all my billing to come in at the
first of the month or should I keep it
like it is kind of sports throughout the
month so there's always money coming in
is this really your biggest problem well
actually my biggest problem is when i'm
only making about to 2025 hundred
dollars a month right what do I pay
myself well I wondering are you at three
hundred bucks a month is not a lot of
money for a really important service
that you're providing well I and you
know and I agree and I'm good at what I
do and I do get results and I get
accolade from my client but my clients
are everything from pageant girls to
fitness experts and authors and so who
in the stage they're in they don't have
a lot of income to pay me I mean my
highest paying client to do that as most
of my time and essentially what it
breaks down to about twenty five dollars
an hour
my time so my main client that pays me
four hundred dollars a month he's
blowing and going and lovin my services
and unaffordable to him on his success
level but for my pageant girls and their
parents and sponsors you know it's it's
affordable and I know you know you kind
of love working with those people to
write those pain I do you really have to
figure out how to get the clients who
can afford to pay you what you're worth
okay and it's important to if you love
those pageant girls and you know they're
never gonna have the budget for you you
can always keep a portion of your
business that's it's not charity but
it's almost charity like you at 25 bucks
an hour is almost charity oh yeah so
what I would encourage you to do is like
how they pay you at the begin of the
Monday that's not that's not your
problem you got to figure out how to get
more of those people who don't just pay
400 bucks month but like a thousand
bucks a month or more how do you get
there what types of minds are those guys
and they may be people who are more
established to have better budgets than
the pageant girls and if the pageant
girls are still like something you love
keep a portion for them but like you got
to make this thing happen right I want
your business to succeed and I'm thank
you and you're you're just making my
mind percolate and you're right I see
what you're saying about making the
pageant thing like a division just a
division not as part of my artist
management and then with the success
that I've got of my clients that that
I'm working with his artist manager that
are paying four hundred dollars a month
you know once we've hit the you know my
agreements are six months once it hit
the milestones which we're hitting and
we'll be on track for actually two
months earlier than our goals that we
set um and I think I can go out and
confidently say it what go from four
hundred to a thousand dollars a month
hey I love this thinking this is good so
okay here's what i would do they start
to sorry i have two plans for you okay
you ready yeah the first one is have
something like that written in advance
so for the first six months is going to
be four hundred bucks a month and then
it's going to increase the thousand
dollars a month that's written in stone
for every new person that comes on board
so they understand that and they know
they're not getting the value
they're not gonna stick around after six
months right you're not locking them to
your contract yeah the second thing is
if you really love this pageant thing
find a way to still help them but not
make it as time intensive so maybe you
can do groups right maybe you can do
training with them or webinars or group
classes something where you can help
lots of people at once or if you're
representing people to the media you can
give them a bunch of options so there's
a weight is still helpful but more as
scale for you I see yes and webinars or
skype classes or Google hangout or
whatever everybody's doing is actually
more time intensive to you know no
travel costs no room costs no nothing
right and you can help multiple people
at the same time and maybe that's
something that is worth 300 bucks a
month that's worth your 25 bucks an hour
because now you're helping 25 people at
once so then would you say that I can go
ahead and raise my prices January first
and Institute that new clause about a
thousand dollars after six months and
then tell my pageant girls that we're
going to start doing group classes this
often for this amount of money yeah I
mean you got to face it in for every new
person this is the contract you have to
sign and then you phase in your client
you know it may be a big shock to them
at the start but you can phase it in for
them so that you know you don't want to
lose all their business but your face it
in and let them know this is what I'm
doing and hopefully you should be okay
to the scene great value from you and
then my marketing brings me in better
people so my target market might change
as far as where I'm where I'm doing my
little marketing budget you got a case
you got it and you can bet everyone
Richie's business you got it thank you
thank you no problem welcome back to the
oven Carmichael show I believe in
entrepreneurs I want to see you have
massive success with your company and
part of that is bringing on a team you
got to build this thing beyond yourself
because if you want to change the world
you can't do it alone I get a question
as a lot to me how do I pay my first
employees and you're thinking from the
wrong point of view at the start
here okay because if you are only trying
to compete on how much it going to pay
and the benefits you're going to offer
you're going to lose you're going to
lose because the big companies are
always going to be able to pay more and
offer better benefit and I don't want
you to settle for mediocre talent the
way to bring on employees is stand for
something important ninety percent of
America they wake up and they drop the
job that they hate and they can't wait
for quitting time to come so they can go
home and relax and do with their family
if your company stands or something is
doing something important people will
want to come and work for you and
they'll accept a lower salary and
they'll accept lower benefits because
this is what they'd love to do you're
giving the meaning people are searching
for meaning that's how you compete
you're never going to be able to pay the
highest prices if you got some you know
rich uncle who's funding you and it says
yes whenever you want then fine but you
know what for most of us entrepreneurs
we don't have that kind of backing but
you have a leg up on these big companies
because those guys they don't stand for
anything nobody feels inspired working
have a huge company you have a chance to
change the lives of your employees and
give them some meaning that's what you
got to put front and center now you
still have to pay you know you have to
pay your employees obviously but the
most important fact if somebody's gonna
come work for you not be not going to be
because of the money so figure out what
that is what are you stand for you got
to figure it out yourself first but most
companies don't stand for anything
what's a change you're trying to make in
the world and communicate that you can
start attracting employees want to be on
your team I have Laura on the line where
are you from and how can I help I'm from
st. Louis Evan did I loop of what you're
talking about I have a piece of property
that has a spring on it and i would love
to sell the spring water and have the
part of the profits go to the the the
energy on the land is very Native
American so I would like to honor the
land and have a percentage of the
profits go to Native American though
girls and I am trying to
figure out how I can structure that the
business and be able to pay people but I
have people in my life right now that
are one of them is his specialty is like
water testing I didn't realize he was in
my circle and so I'm trying to figure
out how I can begin the business because
right now it's just a raw spring I have
people who can help me and there's a
part of me that is a really big giver
sometimes too much fur so how can I
bring the people in to shift me on the
front end so that i can pay them as it
gets up and running and pay them in a
way that I'm still a functioning
profitable business absolutely now are
you Native are you part Native I am not
only just in spirit okay I like that's a
good answer i like that he so you have
some of the team already like you know
these people but what you haven't
approached them you have in mind
anything up what's happening we all be
there in my circle and I one of them i
was saying well I really wanted he's
been helping me with this property cuz
i'm doing a spiritual retreat here and I
said you know I really want to sell the
spring water it's come to me very
clearly several times and he said oh
well I used to work in a kidney dialysis
place and I was in charge of making sure
the water was pure because it was part
of the process so I know all about that
Bruce and I was wonderful I was excited
but I knew somebody that knew a whole
lot more about water testing and
checking than I did and he's not working
right now so he has some flexibility and
would love to help me and I would like
to be able to say here's how i can pay
you later because he would just he's
just opened to assist in whatever way
right possible so what i would first do
is think about is this guy is he a giver
too and it sounds like he wants to help
out his early in your circle but it's
important for anybody who you bring on
if you embody give and that's that's
part of what you're doing with your
spring right you want to give back to
the Native community even though you're
not native write like this is given at
its best you need people who also
believe in that giving mentality good
right so everybody you bring on has to
be give even if they you know you want
people with the skills this guy has the
water skills that's great but they also
have to have that giving mentality to
work with you learn otherwise you're
going to you're going to clash it's not
going to work right and he has been I
also do spiritual coaching and so I've
been working with he and his wife and
and he's just been through a huge
transformation and so he feels he's not
paying me for that but he's come out and
split wood on the land and and just
helps and helping me structure a lot of
other things so he's very much a giver
and wants to give back in probably
similar ways that I give or different
ways that I guess so so in being a giver
event which is obviously great to play
with people who play like you do how can
I also then at some point when that it
becomes profitable it becomes a
financially viable experience in
business you know there's part of me
that says okay he's going to say well
where's my check right okay so the first
thing I understand is those two things
are not mutually exclusive you can't be
a giver and make a lot of profit and I
feel like don't holding you back you
think I can't be a giver and make money
and be a good business person that's you
can be a great business person and a
great giver and and some of the best
entrepreneurs in the world are huge
givers you still have to have the
business sense and that's fine and and
you you know you're going to that
process but you can still be who you are
and it's only going to be a huge asset
to your company just like I was talking
about a stance or something right so
right you don't it's hard to figure out
exactly how to compensate him right now
because you don't know right how much
time is going to put in you don't know
how much money going to make out of it
but trust that
it will work I Randall through this this
will work and you will find a way and
you're not being jealous you're not
being greedy you know you're going to
compensate him fairly and if you bring
on people who are like-minded who
believe the same thing then that helps
build the trust in a relationship right
so I will turn all structured and
everything yet until you have more
information sure well and I guess I want
to be I want to be an integrity and I
want to be mindful about that so what
what how this is really helping the evan
is it it is giving me the opportunity to
be able to to be straightforward done
communicated so there so that on the
back end there isn't this oh well I
thought you were going to yes tell him
honestly what you feel like I'm a giver
I want this to work I think it can work
i don't know how it's going to work yet
but i think we could do something great
together and go along and see how it
plays out it's wonderful okay i'm
excited for you thanks a million I so
appreciate your help no problem I
believe in entrepreneurs I want to see
you rake in the customers and have an
impact and I get asked a lot by
businesses who are starting up how do i
convince customers to buy something how
do i convince a customer the Bison and
again this is the wrong question because
I don't believe you have to convince
anybody to do anything they should want
to do it this goes back to our last
segment about getting employees you
shouldn't have to convince people to
come and work for you if you have to
convince you they're not the right
person i miss feel the same way about
customers invince somebody to work for
you convince some of the buy from you
they're not the right person and what
ends up happening is what you get
desperate you drop your prices and
you're racing to the bottom and it's not
a winning strategy because it's always
going to be somebody who undercut you
that somebody will do it for free
somebody will lose money on it you can't
cut your prices what you need to do is
come up with something that makes you
different right Lauren our last segment
she's all about giving
just going to attract employees who want
to give she's going to track customers
who loved her message of gift that's
what's going to make her spring water
different because otherwise it's just
water what's so different about water
you need to find the same thing for your
business why do people buy some
companies like Nike is okay if I'm a
basketball player by Nike shoe why do I
buy a Nike shoe is because I want to be
like LeBron James that's what nike makes
me feel what is your company make feel
probably nothing but you know what I
accept most business but you're not that
far behind people are buying from the
best of the worst if you can start to
stand for something important customers
will want to work with you you'll be a
magnet you don't have to go out and
convince people this shouldn't be about
hard selling people and following up do
you like when people hard sell you and
call you every day hey you ready to buy
you ready to buy doesn't work my
frustration comes out of a conversation
I had with my agent a little dispute but
if and I'm working on this deal okay
we're working on this deal big deal
sushi special impact and haven't heard
back from the other party for a while I
made it says hey Evan you know you
should follow up follow up with them and
see what's going on you know starts and
what's up I don't follow up with people
I told them hey you can follow up but I
don't follow up this is not part of my
business and it's not like it's not
because I'm some big ego maniac and I'm
the best in the world it's because the
people who you have to follow up with
and follow up with I follow up with but
they're never going to be great
customers I don't want to waste my time
on it and you shouldn't either you
should spend your time with something
important not chasing down people and
trying to convince them that what you
have is great the people who you have to
keep calling on are never going to be
your best customers the Heidi convince a
customer to buy from you you don't you
spend your time building something that
is going to attract people in building
something important taking a stance on
something
then you don't have to worry and you
spend your time on something productive
so I'm not going to follow up with that
person and I don't follow up with any of
the big clients that I work with and
some people get what I do and some
people don't and that's fine I just
don't want to spend my time on somebody
who doesn't get what I do you know my
business is all about belief believe in
an entrepreneur right i hope that oozes
through everything I do from the radio
show youtube videos everything the
caller's I believe in entrepreneurs I
want to see be successful I think
entrepreneur's can change the world you
have a powerful message the world needs
what you're doing I believe that and
some of the companies I work with they
believe that too and they want to work
with me because nobody else is talking
about this so they want to work with me
and the companies who don't believe that
that's cool you know I'm not going to
convince you that this is important and
you should feel the same way if you
stand for something important then you
shouldn't have to convince people that
is right the ones who believe it will be
your best customers so buy from you
they'll spread your message and those
are the ones you want to focus on I want
to get to the calls i have Amanda on the
line Amanda where are you from and how
can I help hi I'm some long islands and
I recently just considered opening up my
own hair salons and I just saturated
from school and I have a degree in
marketing I'm kind of loan money and I
have a ton of loans that I'd still need
to pay off I want to open it as soon as
possible so i can start paying off those
loans but I currently work in a
marketing firm in Manhattan I was just
wondering what's the quickest way you
get my business started sure where you
working out at a bar sorry you're
working at a bar right now I'm working
at a marketing firm and marketing firm
butcher yeah what you want to start a
hair salon I just always had a passion
in in hair and I don't know I just feel
like it's a good way to make my money
and I'll just be happy and it's not a
nine to five and I make my own schedule
so
have you already started doing this on
the side friends family I kind of stuff
I've been doing a lot on my friends and
everything I had an internship in high
school for at a hair salon so I just not
experience but I just really want to
open up my own and be my own boss and I
want to start paying off these loans I
just don't want to be in debt for the
rest of my life right and so you know
starting a hair spa is going to cost a
lot of money too haha so what I would
encourage you to think about how can you
start this thing small so you're not out
lean use cash oh right can you start
with in a current hair salon or within
somebody doesn't even do here but it's
related like a nail salon or something
like guys get a chair I've considered
that I probably wouldn't mind that just
because it is my passion and I have to
start to the bottom studies like the
other class but feel to my goal with to
be to open up my hair salon but I know
it's best not practical right now
because I do I just came out of college
and this marketing firm I'm doing pretty
well for myself pusillus it's still kind
of hard it's just not practical open up
my own hair a lot so started from the
bottom now we're here exactly okay so
what's holding you back why haven't you
gone and done that you get a chair at
somebody else's salon I just I was like
I mean I know it's not an excuse that
I've been busy it's just that I did just
finished like finished college and also
my parents really don't think that it's
a practical job for me they want me to
do something do you want me to
definitely do something and marketing
but they don't think that opening up the
hair salon is the most practical thing
for me and that I think that's reason
that's holding you back pretty much I
mean that's the ultimate thing for me I
just why should I go out and I like I
want to pursue my dreams and I want to
continue to see what I want to do but if
my parents are going to tell me like
those parents are always right so should
I listen to them or should i do what i
want to do not really okay so let me
give you some advice from michael dell
michael dell's the founder of dell dell
computer okay it was in University and
it
opt out and he said oldest parents I
want to take the summer off to do this
computer business and if but if it
doesn't work i'll go back to school but
if it doesn't work then i'm going to
keep doing it and that gave them the
confidence to say you know you gave him
his blessing because they always thought
I he's not going to make it and he'll go
back to school anyway what do you made
it my teacher became you know
billionaire right so being able to say
something like that like give me a year
I'm exploring like some some people out
the college to go and they travel for a
year this is a time to do your self
exploration see what you really want to
do before you get locked into a career
and it becomes super hard to escape
that's the one about that kind of deal
with your parents to say listen I want
to try this for one year this is
something I really want to do one year
if it doesn't work i'll go back to
marketing yeah i mean i think that's a
great compromise either I didn't know
how to kind of get them I want them to
just meet me halfway kind of thing but I
definitely think that that's the start
you know they love you there trying to
think about the best view that's where
it's coming from mm-hmm right yeah
definitely you still got to do your
thing especially now that was the time
because when you're 40 and locked into
this marketing career and you have you
know kids and all this other stuff
around you it's super hard to break out
uh-huh definitely yes sir and I have I
feel like I have the job and I have the
ability and definitely these great
things so Oh we'll get a go in if I'm in
Long Island let me know where to come
for my haircut okay for sure definitely
alright thanks aranda de like you so
much I like no problem hey for everybody
listen is going to be people who doubt
you we don't believe in you that's part
of the Entrepreneurship path you got to
take if you believe that this is the
right thing to do you got to have the
courage to go after it hey we all have
fear we all have worries we all have
doubters but when you have the courage
to fight through that's what makes a
difference in successful entrepreneur
one who quit
believe in entrepreneurs I want to see
you turn your dream into reality and I
get asked a lot should I leave my job to
focus on my business here's the thing
okay it's a great quest the challenge
most people face is you don't know how
hard it is the sort of business and if
you quit too soon what often happens is
you end up running out of cash and
having to go back and get that job that
you're at and it's demoralizing however
hard you think it's going to be usually
when we you know women prepare very
little about it you think about okay
here's my best case is my worst case but
if your worst case is it's way harder
than that you ask any successful
entrepreneur and a lot of them will say
if I knew how hard it wasn't the one
even started it's crazy hard but it's
okay you can overcome it it's possible
but I don't want you to be part of that
eighty percent who fail because you run
out of cash right you only have so much
cash at some point you need to find the
way to get some cash so great way to do
it is to keep your job keep your job
start your business part-time and
ideally you're in a job that is training
you to be a better entrepreneur you're
learning skills that will help you in
your business and get it to the point
your business where you're at survival
where you're paying your bills you can
pay your rent you can pay your your
mortgage you're not you're not making it
large here okay it's not the life of
luxury but you can survive when you get
there that's when you quit your job and
go full time if you do too soon you're
running a cash and then having to go
back to get a job I don't want that for
you okay I want to get to the calls one
last college today I have Andre on the
line Andre where are you from and how
can I help hey I'm from I'm originally
from Chicago but right now I live in Los
Angeles California all right what's
going on right now will add my business
planning my business portfolio together
I'm working as an administrative
assistant so I get to do a lot of the
groundwork involved with you a lot of
different distances and I'm looking to
buy now what should be the next step and
my uh I guess my decision to move
forward you want to start a business
what do you want you want to have a
career what are you trying to do
yes the sort of business I want to start
my own it's kind of like it's kind of
corporate it's it's a combination I
found Billy corporate but it's something
that's very commercialized I want to
kind of start my own studio glass also
it's gonna have like I guess a coffee I
kind of like my own more active more
physically sick version of starbucks
okay well well I thought you dig studio
you went out for coffee shop or studio
no it's going to be a combination of the
two so above the starbucks it would be a
studio facility pepe with host like yoga
classes and why there can I some things
like that just kind of or maybe even
just one of those CrossFit or post
Pilates type of things at it watch it so
where did you cope with this idea I want
to know I came up with the idea idea
just hanging out in santa monica with a
bunch of friends in between once and
just seeing the type of people that uh
that are running around in the mornings
thing like the different personalities
like everyone come in and get a coffee
and there in like their work out the
tire you know like girls in there
they're leggings and their little
fitness hoodies and then guys are coming
in like they're running season their
expressions that's just like they're
coming to get coffee and they're leaving
these coffee shots when they're going
down to like 24 hour fitness or the LA
fitness in it Cena to become active to
work out and okay why is this important
for you why does this have to happen
personally I'm really into fitness um I
work out every day I'm very physically
say I don't drink coffee but do drink
green tea and I feel like it's a chance
to get out of the rat race now I've been
in there most people in their entire
lives and in my entire life so I'm ready
for a change here so the thing you got
going here is you're talking big box to
make this thing happen definitely so how
do you make this how do you start like
how do you do this on a smaller scale
they start building a community and a
movement around this well I see it as
first if I can find well there's a
couple locations I've been looking at
and then I've talked to people about
there's areas where i can do i can leave
a studio space like I can leave the
studio which is like a two-story
building and I can do I can make a
coffee shop or tournament kitchen area
of kanuda two stories to do gimmick the
kitchen area into kind of like a Java
hat or a coffee coffee shop and then
that upper level can always be the
studio for the yoga classes and offices
the physical life is gonna pay for all
this uh me and I feel my friends who've
come on board with the idea dad you have
enough cash to do it right now to rent
the space they have enough cash to rent
the space ages merchandise and you know
we're just working up to getting ready
for the merchandise and things like that
I mean that studio is one thing this is
an empty space but a copy shop is a ton
of expenses to make that happen can you
say that I can you start to do have some
kind of twist to it you know your own
flavor to it something different and
then like base to coffee shop yeah
things to that that's what we're really
concerned with the soup here we kind of
have it down but the coffee shop is a
little bit more complex and so we're
just going to figure out what would be
the best approach or the smartest
approach when trying to get into that
type of industry okay so this is this is
the same with any any big vision any big
dream that entrepreneur has okay so you
have a picture of the future that you
want to have but often there's so many
things to make that happen as you get so
discouraged and you don't do anything
about it yeah and so the best way to
start is to start like break it down
smaller chunks do something now that you
can move forward on that if the next
logical step is the studio and you have
the cash to do it and you know what
you're going to teach you got
instructors and you got your friends on
board and you know you have the business
case port start with that and you know
like base 2 is going to be coffee shop
or maybe something different you know
like as you get into your your studio
space may discover new things different
ways to grow the important thing is to
get started on it so that you don't just
get overwhelmed with all the details is
a big project that end up doing nothing
hmm so you're saying just open up open
up the studio in peace of the classes in
their way there integrate coffee shop
aspect yeah absolutely we're in the
University and on its own it's something
special you need different about the
studio like how long have you wanted to
do this we've developed it over eight
months eight months okay and like have
you actually gone out and done anything
yet yeah we've gone and looked at a
couple of different different locations
you know that's always a huge factor in
this area locations locations that I'm
just timing tact with the price because
over poster Hollywood Boulevard type of
deal yeah well I mean sounds like you're
motivated you're taking steps this is
great but i would definitely chunk it
down start with a small start with the
studio I'm build up from there and then
like you don't have to be a little 21
right this could go national insurance
yeah that's what I was hoping for house
that's something I that's a built-in one
just get that one studio okay Andre yes
absolutely good luck everybody destiny
thank you so much I have another great
show thank you to my producers doc and
Fernanda love you guys you always
deliver have a great new years I will
see you in January believe